I was an English major Yale which in
retrospect was a really good way to
prepare to be a science writer although
I didn't realize it at the time that my
only regret from my years as an
undergraduate is that I didn't take more
classes in science
I would write about evolution because
that way I've got four billion years of
life at my disposal and I don't think
I'd ever get bored of that I'm not so
worried about the further evolution of
the human species I'm just worried about
its survival and well-being and I think
that probably the biggest immediate
thing would be global warming because
it's going to push the planet into a
state that we've never experienced as a
civilization Jurassic Park where you're
actually resurrecting dinosaurs no
because DNA doesn't survive for tens of
millions of years but what about a
passenger pigeon which was extinct about
a hundred years ago maybe you could
extract DNA out of passenger pigeon
specimens from museums and reconstruct
his genome and stick that DNA in a
pigeon egg and see what happens the
essence of biology is evolution because
everything that's alive has the capacity
to evolve whether it's a virus or
dinosaur or us we all have what it takes
to evolve it's just baked into our
biology
you
if we clone the Edit alls I think they
need human rights they were clearly
capable of some pretty extraordinary
thought processes that you know only we
humans have on earth today
well we don't know what other forms of
life can exist until we go find it or
make it and they're actually scientists
who are trying to do exactly that some
people have suggested that maybe instead
of DNA which is got two strands you
could have jeans on one strand a
molecule called RNA and they're actually
been serious scientist who had some
really wild alternative ideas maybe life
could be made of silicon instead of
carbon we don't know until we go looking
the answer is about 20 miles an hour and
that applies to European and African
swallows and there is a very good
website here where you can see why
you
you